hola cómo te va aquí tengo el problema
17 en el cual nos creamos la vez pasada
sin embargo muchas veces por cuestiones
de presión del tiempo o por no querer
hacer un vídeo muy largo me apresuro y
no lo veo con calma entonces quiero
retomar la solución de este problema
número 17 y que entiendas de una manera
muy adecuada porque me tomé el valor de
3 y el valor de menos 2 y porque te dije
que a los puntos más extremos que hacían
la pendiente más grande así que para
esto déjame borrar todo esto que tengo
aquí déjame quitarlo y también voy a
quitar todo esto que tengo aquí esto no
me sirve déjame quitarlo porque ahorita
lo voy a trabajar de una manera distinta
entonces olvidemos todo esto y de hecho
creo que sería más fácil hasta haber
borrado todo el pizarrón pero bueno
trabajemos ahora si en este problema
este problema que me gustó mucho el
problema número 17 y decía que teníamos
esta curva x igual a ye cuadrada menos 4
y sustituyendo el valor de x
con 0 y el valor de x con 5 habíamos
llegado a que los dos puntos de
intersección podrían ser los puntos 0,22
espero que eso si lo recuerdes y los
puntos 5,2 menos 3 aquí tengo cuatro
puntos posibles en donde se pueda
interceptar mi recta l con esta curva
que tengo aquí ahora quiero que los veas
gráficamente entonces para esto voy a
decir que este es mi eje de las íes y
que este de aquí es mi eje de las x
entonces vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa
con estos puntos si estos dos son mis
ejes déjame ponerle aquí este es mi eje
de leyes este de aquí es mi eje de asx
como se ven estos cuatro puntos gráfica
2 bueno tengo el punto 0,2 el punto cero
como más 2 voy a suponer que es este de
aquí este es el punto 0,2 y por acá
abajo entonces voy a tener el punto cero
como al menos 20 menos 2
aquí ya tengo mis dos primeros puntos
después tengo el 5 3 10 5 menos 3
entonces voy a suponer que aquí es mi
valor de 5 en x y entonces tengo un
punto más o menos por aquí voy a suponer
que este es el 53 y bueno para abajo
también tengo el 5 como menos 3 que
estará como por aquí
este es el 5 como menos tres muy bien
ahora que ya tengo estos cuatro puntos
quiero que veas todas las posibles
rectas que pueden pasar por estos cuatro
puntos en primer lugar puedo tener estas
dos rectas con pendiente positiva este
de aquí que pase por estos dos puntos o
puedo tener esta otra recta con
pendiente positiva estas dos rectas
pasan por dos de estos puntos que estoy
graficando muy bien ahora también puedo
tener dos rectas con pendientes
negativas es decir puedo tomarme esta de
aquí esta sería una de ellas y la otra
sería pues estar acá pero a mí lo que me
pide el problema es cuál de estas cuatro
rectas tiene la pendiente
máxima y fue por eso que lo que busqué
fue el mayor cambio en y quiero que te
des cuenta que la distancia en x no
cambian estamos desde 0 hasta 5 el
cambio en x se mantiene siempre
constante delta de x es el que nos va a
cambiar y lo que puede cambiar es mi
valor en yen y el valor más grande que
me puedo tomar en qué es todo este salto
de aquí es decir tomarme todo esto de
acá hasta acá
este sería el mayor cambio en que puedo
tomar ahora bien las únicas dos rectas
que tienen esta altura en james es esta
recta de color rojo que tengo aquí y
esta recta de color azul que tengo aquí
y entonces si tengo estas dos rectas una
tiene pendiente positiva y la otra tiene
pendiente negativa y fue por eso que
elegí esta recta con mi recta con
pendiente máxima porque tiene pendiente
positiva y además tiene el mayor cambio
en game y entonces me tomé el punto 53 y
el punto 0 - 2
cuando calculé está pendiente tres menos
dos entre 50 y llegué a que la pendiente
máxima que podría tener esta recta es de
1 muy bien entonces espero que ya te
queda un poco más claro todo esto para
que podamos ir a trabajar con el
siguiente problema una vez ya borrada la
pantalla ya podemos trabajar con el
problema número 18 que por cierto dice
es un problema este manejo al trabajo
durante la mañana a una velocidad
promedio de 45 kilómetros por hora así
que vamos a ponerlo aquí bajar desde su
casa hasta el trabajo manejo desde su
casa al trabajo entonces vamos a poner
aquí su casa por acá está el trabajo y
va a manejar en la mañana de la casa al
trabajo con una velocidad de 45
kilómetros por hora
y esto es
la mañana la segunda parte del problema
dice que por la tarde ella regresa a la
casa por el mismo camino pero esta vez
con una velocidad promedio de 30
kilómetros por hora así que esto es lo
que pasa en la mañana pero en la tarde y
lo voy a poner con color de tarde ella
va a ir del trabajo hasta su casa pero
ahora va a ir con una velocidad de 30
kilómetros por hora 30 kilómetros por
hora y esto es en la tarde muy bien y
bueno todo esto porque ojo
quiero leerte de nuevo esta parte del
problema dice por la tarde ella regresa
a casa por el mismo camino creo que eso
nos va a servir bastante y bueno dice si
el tiempo total de los dos recorridos es
de una hora entonces cuántos kilómetros
manejo esther de su trabajo a la mañana
y bueno este creo que es uno de los
problemas típicos de distancia es igual
a velocidad por tiempo estos dos típicos
problemas
velocidad promedio y entonces utilizando
esta fórmula vamos a encontrar la
solución porque porque aquí se divide en
dos el problema que es lo que pasa
primero en la mañana mañana en la mañana
este va a recorrer una cierta distancia
de su casa al trabajo que le voy a poner
de él y esta va a ser igual a la
velocidad pero la velocidad está dada
por 45 kilómetros programa entonces la
distancia va a ser igual a 45 kilómetros
por hora por el tiempo entonces voy a
poner que este es un tiempo te deum o si
lo quieres ver de esta manera y esto es
lo que pasa en la mañana por la tarde
que es lo que va a pasar por la tarde
ella va a realizar por el mismo camino
es decir que la distancia va a ser la
misma la distancia del trabajo a la casa
va a ser la misma porque esther se
regresa por el mismo camino muy bien
esto es en la tarde y esto va a ser
igual a la velocidad a la que ella va en
la tarde que por cierto disminuyó tal
vez había mucho tráfico o tal vez había
una manifestación no
pero el chiste es que ella regresa del
trabajo a la casa con una velocidad de
30 kilómetros por hora una velocidad de
30 kilómetros por hora
por el tiempo pero quién es este tiempo
aquí viene lo más importante de este
problema porque me dice el problema que
el tiempo total de los dos recorridos es
decir el tiempo del recorrido uno más el
tiempo del recorrido dos esto es igual a
una hora y esto me va a servir bastante
porque voy a poder expresar el tiempo
dos como función del tiempo uno fíjate
bien si yo despejó de aquí el tiempo 2
me va a quedar que el tiempo 2 es igual
a 1 menos el tiempo 1 y entonces en
lugar de poner el tiempo 2 aquí voy a
poner 1 menos el tiempo 1 es decir que
en la tarde aplicando la fórmula de
distancia es igual a velocidad por
tiempo en la tarde ella va a recorrer la
misma distancia a una velocidad de 30
kilómetros por hora en un tiempo de 1
um
y así ya tenemos dos ecuaciones con 25
gritas y además aquí está súper padre
porque estamos hablando de la misma
distancia y si la distancia es la misma
esto quiere decir que 45 por tf1 esto es
igual a 30 que multiplica a 1 menos de 1
muy bien y de aquí ya es muy fácil
resolver para el tiempo 1 si yo lo que
hago es distribuir este 30 me va a
quedar que 45 veces el tiempo 1 es igual
a 30 menos 30 veces el tiempo 1 y ahora
si sumo 30 veces del tiempo uno de ambos
lados de la ecuación que me va a quedar
más 30 veces el tiempo 1 más 30 veces el
tiempo 1 y entonces aquí me quedan 75
veces el tiempo 1 es igual a 30 porque
estos dos se van y si de aquí debido a
todo entre 75 me va a quedar que el
tiempo 1 es igual a 3
entre 75 que por cierto esto es lo mismo
que si yo saco una quinta arriba y
quinta abajo me va a quedar 6 entre 15 y
más aún estos dos todavía tienen tercera
entonces puedo dividir entre 13 arriba y
entre 3 abajo me va a quedar dos quintos
ya tengo el tiempo 1 el tiempo 1 es dos
quintos pero recuerda que es lo que me
preguntaban no me preguntaban el tiempo
uno lo que realmente me preguntan es
cuántos kilómetros manejó este a su
trabajo en la mañana es decir yo lo que
quiero saber es la distancia y para
sacar la distancia podemos obtenerla
desde esta ecuación o desde esta otra
ecuación pero creo que la primera es
mucho más sencillo la distancia que es
lo que me piden es igual a 45 por dos
quintos y cuánto es esto bueno sí divido
45 entre 59 y entonces 9 por 2 es 10
18 km es lo que recorre esther y esta es
la solución del problema número 18 y por
cierto con este problema qué creés
acabamos la sección 9 del examen 1 de la
parte de matemáticas del s atn así que
en el próximo vídeo empezaré una nueva
sección espero te hayas divertido